good morning job I'm recording my
vlogbrothers video right now doing my
punishment I have here a shot-caller as
I'm gonna do a makeup challenge but also
every time we raise $200 is I gonna get
a trivia question asked to me we get the
trivia question wrong then I will get
shot yeah so providing the trivia for me
is Dave who works on truth or Phil
trivia this is Meghan yesterday I posted
a photo at last year's makeup Catherine
was the first person to comment on it
and she said the worst keep bringing me
back to fuel your nightmares now asked
if she had an idea for a theme this year
yeah and she said I don't know something
cute can I do goth but cute
let's do coffee cute two pumps of a kind
of moisturizer
I need that it's so dry in this town all
right I feel good I feel moist around us
yeah things that Hank should know about
is companies and employees trivia
question about you guys
yes that makes me very nervous of course
is a crash course had there been a teen
on in some triangular patterns should i
under your eyes you're just joined up I
feel like that about Rachel and Sam what
was the name of the school where they
met i accentuating error collarbones the
cheeks are your color what was the
subject of the first episode a session a
non-newtonian fluids yes
how many of your Missoula employees
graduates tuna do what this cubed off
push it in to the pores of your skin
that's good that's very nice
which two employees share a birthday
apparently you need Vaseline to prepare
for lipstick you can't you put lipstick
on you got a prep if I'm gonna put on a
lot just how much feels nice how do you
put stuff on your eyelid suggest you
[Music]
yeah
there are six podcasts at least that are
recorded in this building uh-huh
what's your podcast called I love it
[Music]
we're all aligned towards the end of
your eyebrow and then you make a
straight line from here to there okay
there's that cute if you're doing it
he's doing it oh wow
too much on at least four of your
employees we're making YouTube videos
before coming to work free Maya Nicole
Stefan yeah this is bad I did a bad job
oh boy got a new respect due respect I
blinked right into it which of your
employees what that's Julie jocks put a
mask area which I do not know how to do
donate very fast so we can ask during
mascara please who is the tallest of
your employees I don't know I don't see
height thanks trying to figure out
liquid
it is like dozen lipstick just make you
go wow this is cute I think probably not
now that you think about it yeah don't
so I could get shocked more what is the
first time that you and John were in a
vlogbrothers video together
were we in the dominican republic yeah I
just did an inner key symbol is that
okay anarchy skin so a league isn't put
a link to how many nautical miles at sea
Hank twelve teeth has some lipstick on
it okay I'm gonna go like this oh my god
hey there boys and girls
okay what am i serving tacos thanks to
Megan for helping out with this links to
all of her stuff are in the description
and thinking everyone from making this
another amazing project for awesome John
I'll see you on Tuesday